ciliates have a more refined approach to
pooping which is to say they have the
unicellular equivalent of an anus called
a cytoproct
ciliates gather food into an oral Groove
and then consume it in the digestive
vacuoles that travel through the cell
eventually when the vacuole makes its
way to the cytoproct the contents get
out and there you have ciliate poop but
having a digestive system with a
distinct entrance and exit is pretty
handy too
for one it's just a little less
disgusting but it also keeps food
flowing in One Direction and that means
animals like the tardigrade and us don't
have to wait to finish digesting to eat
more food we just get to keep eating all
thanks to that evolutionary mystery that
is the anus